je ne sais pas si vous êtes comme moi
mais moi j'ai beaucoup de chance j'ai
beaucoup de chance de manière générale
dans la vie et dans ma vie
professionnelle aussi ça fait des années
que mon job est un super poste
d'observation où j'ai pu rencontrer des
centaines de chefs d'entreprises et des
milliers de salariés
aujourd'hui il y à beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ne vont pas très bien
il y a beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises
et de salariés qui sont épuisés qu'ils
ne s'en rendent pas toujours compte
qu'ils sont parfois dans le déni oui oui
ils vont finir vite structure gens
qu'ils ont à faire et puis se reposeront
après une demi journée ce sera bien
suffisant
j'ai fait la même chose j'ai fait la
même chose et ça s'est terminé de
manière assez violente puisque mon corps
m'a dit stop
tu ne veux pas m'entendre et bien moi je
vais arrêter et pour m'arrêter
ça a été relativement simple la maladie
m'a mis dans le commun avec plus aucune
fonction vitale qui fonctionnait
correctement en quelques heures
c'était un méga burn out et j'ai failli
en mourir
j'ai de la chance ou disait je suis
vivante et je vais très bien c'est une
chose la reconstruction a été longue
imaginez en sortant du commun je ne
pouvais même plus écrire maintenant
j'aurai besoin de votre complicité de
votre aide si vous voulez bien
alors je vais demander ou trois
premières rondes dans la salle d'avoir
la joute y est vous lever s'il vous
plaît
merci beaucoup
vous avez sous les yeux des statistiques
pardon vous avez des personnes
merveilleuses devant vous et elles
représentent les résultats d'une étude
menée par tecnologia en 2014 qu'il
établit qu'en france 19% des salariés
cadres et des chefs d'entreprises sont
en situation de burnout statistiquement
vous êtes en situation de burn out c'est
bien sûr des statistiques merci beaucoup
de votre aide c'était très gentil
ces statistiques vont dans le même sens
que les observations sur le terrain dans
libé m
ce sont des entreprises dans lesquelles
on bosse on bosse on bosse énormément
des entreprises dans lesquelles on n'est
pas toujours très heureux des
entreprises dans lesquelles les patrons
et les salariés ne voient pas toujours
ou pas très bien leurs familles et les
personnes qu'ils aiment les entreprises
dans lesquelles on à bout fournir des
efforts on n'arrive pas toujours à la
hauteur de ce qu'on espérait alors moi
je m'interroge est-ce que notre système
entreprenariale est ce que notre système
d'entreprise n'auraient pas atteint ses
limites
d'ailleurs est ce que ce n'est pas notre
système sociétal tout court qui les
auraient atteinte si le système a
atteint ses limites
fournir des efforts ne sert plus à grand
chose alors devons-nous continuer ou
faut-il en changer changer ça fait peur
oui c'est pas facile mais si nous ne
changeons rien est-ce que nous ne
finiront pas par nous faire imposer par
l'environnement ce qui m'est arrivé avec
beaucoup de violence
un stop j'ai beaucoup de chance vous
disais ge et j'en ai beaucoup parce que
mes amis amérindiens m'ont transmis de
grandes richesses
oui j'ai eu la chance de vivre et de
monter une entreprise au plus profond de
la forêt amazonie
n vous imaginez mon métier c'était
d'emmener des personnes dans cette forêt
merveilleuse et de les ramener avec des
étoiles plein les yeux
dans leur grande sagesse et dans leur
manière de vivre bien dans un milieu
objectivement hostile les amis
amérindiens ou toujours enseigné que si
un jour je tombais dans les rapides et
ce sont des rapides à la mesure où
plutôt à la démesure de l'amazone i dont
je vous parle
si je tombais dense et rapide donc la
seule solution est de ne pas résister de
me laisser faire
sinon en nageant à contre-courant je
risque seulement l'épuisement et de
finir noyer
je peux vous dire que pour être tombé
accidentellement dans ses rapides là
assure la vie dette et m'en être sorti
sans un seul bleu j'ai définitivement
compris qu'il ne faut surtout pas
résisté au courant des choses alors que
devons-nous changer dans notre monde
entrepreunarial et surtout comment en
changer j'ai quelques pistes
lorsque j'étais dans le coma et après
pendant de longues semaines j'ai eu la
chance inouïe d'être prises en charge
dans un service de réanimation de points
vous fait un petit coucou d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup je vous dois tellement
dans ce service exemplaire on sauve des
vies
mon souhait des personnes après des choc
d'une violence inouïe accidents et
autres choses terribles
eh bien on cultive ce que nous chefs
d'entreprise nous appellerions
l'expérience client
ça veut dire qu'on soit bien entendu au
plan technique avec des machines et
c'est le job de ces personnes là mais on
estime aussi qu'il est extrêmement
important de chouchouter les malades de
les dorloter de les coûts connus de leur
offrir un maximum
confort je vous donne un seul exemple
parmi un seul parmi toute une kyrielle
de ce que je pourrais vous citer on me
demandait tous les jours à quelle heure
je voulais déjeuner et à quelle heure je
voulais dîner vous imaginez ce que ça
suppose
j'ai eu ensuite lorsque j'allais mieux
la chance de pouvoir discuter avec le
patron de ce service
il m'a dit c'est clé pour que cela
fonctionne la première chose c'est une
crue très grande autonomie des
personnels ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
de hiérarchie le moins possible toutes
les initiatives sont bienvenus la
deuxième clé m'at-il dit c'est que je
refuse de garder dans mon service des
gens qui n'ont plus l'entousiasme qui
n'ont plus cette envie farouche de
sauver des vies et de prêter attention
aux autres et de le faire d'une manière
très humaine vous remettre en forêt
amazonienne vous voulez bien
mon associé d'alors est un excellent
guide et vie en forêt depuis toujours
d'ailleurs il y vit pas il est la forêt
est lassant hilda respire il d'avis il a
fait des tas de boulot là-bas y compris
d'orpaillage clandestin du déboisage et
autre chose et ça fait quelques années
qu'ils travaillent dans des structures
touristiques où on lui demande de guider
correctement bien entendu mais surtout
de ne prendre aucune initiative est
d'avoir aucune idée après quelques mois
de travail dans notre entreprise nous
sommes au début de la saison touristique
et nous avons là un sérieux coup de
trafalgar interdiction de naviguer sur
le fleuve qui est très embêtant puisque
toutes nos excursions partait sur le
fleuve
c'est la voie royale pour se déplacer
là-bas imaginait la trésorerie de
l'entreprise commence à prendre le
bouillon pour ne pas dire qu'elle avait
pris complètement
nous étions baudu au bord du dépôt de
bilan est très stressé
alors il me dit bien aller je t'emmène
quelque part on part en forêt on va
décompresser pour moi pas de soucis au
contraire la forêt amazonienne a
toujours été bien faisant pour moi mais
je m'attendais pas à la surprise qu'il
m'a réservé alors il m'a emmené dans un
endroit absolument incroyable je vous
montre
j'ai pas de très belles photos mais je
vous montre quand même des roches
magnifique énorme des piscines et des
jacuzzis naturel en pleine jungle sous
un couvert végétal complètement préservé
un endroit où on est en totale sécurité
à quelques encablures du village et où
on peut même emmener les enfants en bas
âge
un endroit qui permet d'offrir du rêve
en toute sécurité
lorsque nous étions là-bas il me dit tu
vois je pense qu'ici si nous emmenons
nos clients nous allons leur faire
plaisir
il avait raison nous avons monté ce
produit qui étaient rares voire uniques
sur le marché
ça a été un carton ça a été hyper
successfull tout le monde voulait venir
à greek véronique parce qu'on pouvait y
emmener ses enfants souffrir du rêve et
venir en famille
c'était très simple d'accès c'était
juste magique et ce qui était magique
c'est qu'avec son idée cet homme là ce
jour-là à sauver notre entreprise
il a pu le faire parce qu'il était
passionné par ce qu'il connaissait très
bien la forêt et parce qu'il avait
compris ce qu'attendaient les clients je
suis persuadé que dans toutes les
entreprises
toutes les personnes sont vraiment
talentueuse mais elles le sont à
condition qu'elle fasse ce qu'elle aime
et rien que cela qu'elle le fasse avec
enthousiasme et envie
c'est la même chose les personnes qui
m'ont soigné dans le service de
réanimation
elles sont passionnés par ce que parce
qu'elles font aligné par cette mission
qui est de sauver des vies en le faisant
avec tentes
unité et pas seulement comme des
machines je pense que là il y a quelque
chose à révéler quelque chose à chercher
pour chaque personne de l'entreprise ne
faire que ce qu'on aime qu'on soit
patron ou salariés d'ailleurs et le
faire comme on les aime
vous ne croyez pas que cela nous
permettrait d'économiser des échecs
d'économiser des énergies d'économiser
des chausse-trappes d'économiser des
burnout d'économiser des gens malheureux
moi j'en suis persuadé et sur le terrain
ce que je constate c'est que dans les
entreprises dans lesquelles le patron et
les salariés vont bien dans les
entreprises dans lesquelles ils ne
travaillent pas dans les entreprises
dans lesquelles ils s'amusent dans les
entreprises dans lesquelles on a éliminé
au maximum toutes ces lourdeurs qui tire
vers le bas et qui nous fatigue et
qu'ils nous rendent malades dans ces
entreprises qui génèrent de l'
enthousiasme et qui laisse la place à la
créativité et à l'imagination de chacun
dans ses entreprises dans lesquelles la
hiérarchie est plate
elle n'est pas nécessaire puisque chacun
fait bien ce qu'il aime dans ces
entreprises là souvent on génère des
bénéfices
il faut donc pour moi cessé de prendre
de la peine de s'épuiser à la tâche pour
que cela fonctionne il faut je crois
considérer que la priorité absolue le
terreau de l'entreprise
l envie de tous ces acteurs l'envi de se
faire plaisir et de faire plaisir à ses
clients alors si on peut retrouver
chacun d'entre nous nos missions de vie
ce pourquoi nous sommes là sur cette
terre je pense qu'on va réussir à
changer les choses à être chacun d'entre
nous
un autre juste place alignés et du coup
à revenir à des énergies positives qui
nous permettront de nous lever tous les
matins en ayant retrouvé l'envi de faire
ce qui nous plaît et rien que cela
pour cela on aura peut-être besoin dead
il faudra peut-être faire comme en
amazonie recourir aux chamans mais là je
veux parler du chaman entreprise bien
sûr je me demande si finalement ce n'est
pas cela le graal que nous cherchons
tous nous chefs d'entreprise je me
demande si finalement la pierre
philosophale n'est pas tout simplement
l'envi l'envi de vie l'envi qui nous
permet d'être juste heureux à notre
place et de ne faire que ce qui nous
plaît soyez heureux be happy
c'est tout ce que je vous souhaite ce
soir
[Applaudissements]